hi today we're going to be talking about
how we run Apache airflow at scale at
Shopify
so my name is Jonathan Archer I'm a
staff that engineer at Shopify working
with Michael in the data Foundation
compute team
and I'm Michael and I'm a data engineer
at Shopify also on the data foundations
compute team our team maintains the
compu Primitives the data scientists and
data analysts use to be impactful
specifically query engine and
orchestration
both jam and I focus on developing and
maintaining our custom airflow
infrastructure and Integrations and work
closely with the data reliability team
today we'll be talking about how we use
and deploy airflow at Shopify some
challenges we've encountered running
airflow at scale our new more scalable
multi-instance airflow architecture some
of our custom airflow developer tooling
and what's ahead for our team
so we have four we get into exactly how
we use airflow we should probably
provide an overview of what of what
airflow is to give those who are
unfamiliar with the platform some
context
Apache airflow is an open source
workflow management platform to
programmatically author schedule and
monitor workflows airflow uses dags
which stands for directed acyclic graphs
to orchestrate the order and flow of
tasks in a workflow tags are defined in
Python scripts taking on a configuration
as code approach each dag is defined
along with a set of extensible and
configurable operators that allow for
easy integration with gcp AWS kubernetes
and more
one especially useful feature that
arises from dag files is the ability to
dynamically generate dags using a for
Loop or a config file many uh dags can
be defined in one file airflow also has
user-friendly web client to interact
with dags and view backgrounds
at Shopify we have over 12 000 dags in
production and over 400 000 tasks task
instances running daily while these
numbers sound daunting a lot of our dags
are dynamically generated by data
platform tools and abstractions built on
top of airflow our airflow
infrastructure supports over 600 data
scientists and many core and data
platform internal customers all
supported by JM and me with some help
from the data reliability team
airflow is a foundational component of
our data orchestration platform there
are essentially three types of tags that
we have at Shopify the first is
config-based workflows that dynamically
generate dags from config files or some
data platform abstraction some example
of these include our batch data
ingestion systems that ingest data from
apis and streams as well as Arduino and
bigquery powered DBT modeling platform
the next type of deck is user generated
but takes advantage of complex
Frameworks built into custom operators
like the ml model training pipelines
that we use for custom rate operators
finally we have ad hoc jobs and
individual data scientists that will
need to schedule
airflow is introduced into shopify's
Data platform back in 2019 when
orchestration heavily relied on Uzi and
Azkaban in order to best meet the needs
of data scientists the platform shifted
towards a centralized airflow
environment in 2020. then in 2021 we
upgraded to airflow 2 for huge
performance improvements and after after
migration to airflow was fully complete
this past year through shopify's data
platform growth and scale we've pushed
the limits of what can be run in a
single airflow instance and introduce a
multi-instance architecture improved our
tooling and establish better reliability
practices
um the core components are of airflow
are a set of web servers schedulers and
workers these web the web servers run uh
airflow's web client API the schedulers
handle dag file processing and task
scheduling and the workers execute tasks
at Shopify we run our own in-house
airflow infrastructure on gcp using
Cloud SQL for a managed mySQL database a
mounted file store and GCS for deploying
and sewing tags for each instance of
airflow we deploy airflow's native
components redis as a message broker and
a set of cloud SQL proxies to connect
with Cloud SQL a unique feature of our
infrastructure is the way we combine GCS
and file store to achieve low latency
dag deployments there are two typical
approaches to deploy dags in airflow the
first is storing dags in GCS and
accessing GCS from the airflow
components but introduce introduces
latency issues that um that comes from a
network call limitations
this is what comply this is what cloud
composer does the other standard
approach is baking dates directly into
the airflow image but this creates a
slow iteration speed since each time you
want to make a change to a dag you have
to build a new image and redeploy your
airflow instance
we take a hybrid approach allowing dates
to live in GCS syncing the dag bucket
with a mounted file store using a custom
syncing gamma this allows for the fast
iteration speed of using GCS and reduced
dag update uh latency
now that we've gone over how we use
airflow with Shopify let's talk about
some of the challenges we've come across
running the platform at scale and how
we've over overcome these challenges
so a huge challenge of running system
like airflow with hundreds of internal
use users is managing dag ownership task
resources and ensuring Bank developers
comply with best practices
when you have tens of thousands of dags
in production that are owned by various
teams it can be pretty easy to lose
track of who owns what workflow when dag
when a dag that Services stakeholders
that depend on it works reliably in the
background it can be easy to forget
about who who owns it when it breaks and
you don't know who's responsible it can
be costly in order to maintain a clear
structure of ownership of dags we have
the concept of airflow projects which is
a collection of workflows with a defined
owner Source repository and dedicated K8
namespace as long along with shared
resources and secrets to help with
troubleshooting dag deployments so to
help troubleshooting with dag issues we
append a header to the top of each day
file and deployment with its GCS path
local path git repo and commit
information we also ensure dags meet our
best practices by applying a set of
custom dag validators and mutators this
is a cool customization because we're
not validating or mutating the script
but rather the par stag objects for
example we checked that a diag has a
valid schedule and ensure that the dag
is part of an existing airflow project
we also apply a set of dat mutators to
properly tag dags so that we can filter
them by project and in the future plan
to edit task resources to set uh limits
another significant challenge of running
airflow and scale is dealing with
dependency conflicts when you have a
wide variety of teams using the same
airflow environment installing new
dependencies and resulting conflicts can
be a nightmare this can be especially
difficult pain point when upgrading
airflow versions a great solution that
has become an industry standard is
making use of the kubernetes Pod
operator
this operator allows you to execute your
task in a dedicated kubernetes pod with
a pre-built image that you provide you
can install whatever dependencies you
want into the image and run your task
you don't have to worry about conflicts
so we can we encourage dependency or
resource intensive workflows to take
advantage of these operators this also
makes our airflow image lighter weight
since most of the packages we need to
install are for custom operators and
Integrations
the biggest challenge we faced running
airflow at scale is the scheduler
performance issues the airflow scheduler
does two things primarily date
processing and task scheduling the date
processor parses dag files and updates
the database with dags and and changes
to existing diets the scheduling process
starts new diagrams cues Associated
tasks and assigns them to workers for
execution we found that the scheduler
can be a key bottleneck for task
scheduling latency which can cause dates
to be executed late and date parsing
latency which causes a poor user
experience
to avoid a date processing performance
issues we encourage dag developers to
avoid Network calls and CPU intensive
code in the global scope of dag files
because airflow scheduler will parse
that dag file a primary issue with dag
processing latency is the effect on
developer iteration speeds so we also
have a custom API endpoint that
downloads and processes a date file so
that the developer the developer doesn't
need to wait for the deg processor to
parse their file if it's running slow
foreign
cause of task performance issues at
scale is metadata related when you query
oh sorry when you execute 400 000 tasks
per day it's pretty easy to rack up tens
of millions of rows in airflow database
not to mention the fact that the
scheduler executes complex joins
filtering and ordering in order to find
and prioritize the right tasks to be
executed
to mitigate these metadata related
issues we aggressively truncate our
airflow cables keeping one to four weeks
of diagram and taskets since history we
also make good use of airflow pools and
priority weights to make sure critical
workflows continue to run through
slowdowns
we use MySQL since uh it's the main
database management system at Shopify
but the airflow Community prefers
postgres and it's better supported this
combined with our scale leaves us
finding interesting bugs like missing
indexes or the query planner using the
wrong index so we frequently find
ourselves contributing upstreet fixes
for MySQL
well I've been while we've been able to
manage vertically scaling a single
airflow instance with some of these
mitigation strategies
uh these metadata related challenges tie
into the need to horizontally scale
so that leads us to uh us reading using
multiple instances or adopting the
multi-instance airflow architecture or
in other words sharding or cluster so
next slide
Michael the next slide
thank you
uh so yeah so why why originally scaling
as mentioned earlier vertically scaling
got us pretty far if we think about the
number of attacks we got we actually
reached 400 000 tasks per day with 12
000 tags and the joke is that when we
tell the airflow maintainers about our
scale for them if stress test is about a
thousand tags
so we clearly reached the limit of what
should be reasonable in the western
constants
and also at the same time in the near
future we're about to double or triple
the number of tags we we have so
regardless of whether we want it or not
like we needed to start a sharding our
instances
uh and one of the major issues we add
like as mentioned with uh the list of of
issues we encountered with airflow uh
the blast radius was just massive which
meant that any performance issue an
incident even plan upgrade would
introduce a significant outage or a
significant downtime to all the possible
tags and some of those tags are quite
critical for example other data
ingestion pipeline has discussed is
going through airflow and those can be
quite critical because some of the Kafka
topics that some dags are consuming have
a very short retention period so we've
sometimes we got up to 12 hours to to
get the issue fixed
uh and as mentioned one of the issue is
that also the this as far as having a
support tier for data reliability team
if there was an incident even if the dag
a lot of dags it's not a big issue if
they're down but those that are
interested in dags are quite critical
also we we needed to give them a clear
boundaries where they can when that team
knows when to if any shoe needs to be
jumped on immediately overnight or can
it wait the next day for us to look at
it
uh so in this diagram it's it's no
surprise basically we just end up with
two um well Northern two but quite a few
different distinct airflow instances and
one of the key thing is that right now
we are sharing the same resources so
we're still sharing the same database uh
same database server if we go to next
slide
but they are running on their own
instance uh their own communities
namespaces and whatnot we have the
ability to dedicate specific database
server to different instances if needed
but at this point we have not seen the
need because we were doing the existing
database and other infrastructure was
doing okay enough
uh with a single massive instance so
it's it's keeping up finely or just fine
with the the multiple instances but less
dags or a total the same total amount of
tags I should say
uh so as mentioned we're using the same
J cluster database server GCS bucket and
Fs server and one of the perk of doing
that is that to create a new instance
there's no infrastructure change to be
done on our end so effectively we create
or our clients could create a new little
Json blob on the corner top Corner over
there and that will render all the
kubernetes Manifest required and it will
configure everything perfectly and at
deployment time the everything will be
provisioned so within five minutes
and on top of that we add to make sure
that all our metrics are pretty tagged
uh scope by environment instance tier
name spaces and cluster therefore we
could us and the Dre team could be able
to uh
to clearly see which instance or which
environment is is having some issues and
the key factor or an important thing is
that also every configuration of airflow
itself is also managing the same
deployment pipeline which means that
connections user role mapping pools are
all stored in git and can be applied
consistently across all instances so
it's it's from the upon to go in the
airflow UI or even the command line tool
to change stuff manually
so next slide
one of the challenge we add or or
something we really care about was the
concept of tag routing which effectively
would give us the ability to move dags
to different instances transparently of
the users so as discussed right now all
the teams write their tags to share
diagram repo not repo but the GCS bucket
like an S3 bucket uh but we did not want
them to have to worry about like
modifying their deployment script so
their diet gets deployed to a specific
instance so instead the approach that we
went is that we modified our GCS uh NFS
sync Daemon to uh read from the project
definition file that Michael mentioned
earlier where we specify the instant
name and then the structure the demand
will create a specific structure for the
dags of that specific instance so on the
second image you can see that
uh for the general instance it has a set
of tags that the instance itself can see
where the other instances could not see
them the effective effectively airflow
doesn't know any better it will just
load those tags because that's what you
can see
one of the cab main caveat with that
approach is that uh
when we migrate diags around between
instances right now we do not preserve
this story or The Meta data and also the
depending on how the dag is written the
tag may just execute instantly assume
that the new instance sees the Dag and
another caveat with that is that since
the the direct processors and the two
instances are working independently some
dags may be still be running in the
initial instance and they could start
running instantly on the dnu instance so
depending on if there needs to be
guarantees about like only only one
running at once
uh we would need to shut like delete
make sure that all the tags have been
removed from the old instance make sure
that all the tasks have drained and then
add it to the new instance so there
could be a gap where there's no there's
no Dags
uh next slide
so then where the question comes if we
made it so transparent for a user they
don't have to worry about the dags then
it could get quite confusing about where
dude where are my Dags so how we resolve
that it's since flask is fermented since
airflow is finally just a flask app
quote unquote just uh it means that it's
extremely extensible so we were able to
add the concept of projects to the
airflow UI and also the API so for users
if they're looking for their project
Demps exactly like we if we look at the
second picture they just have to click
and they'll be instantly redirected to
the right instance
uh and same thing we added some extra uh
observability links uh for us and the Dr
team where for example if we click on
the first the link uh highlighted in red
it will link us to a dashboard that is
exactly filtered for the instance and
for the database and for the namespace
and all that stuff so effectively making
sure that the users
The Operators are not overwhelmed with
with unrelevant data
on the API endpoint since we're using
airflow programmatically across like
multiple services and whatnot we also
added the same concept as far as being
able to list instances and mapping
projects uh two instances
and that's a segue into Michael's
so we've developed some custom tooling
to make interacting with airflow easier
surf is a CLI and python library for
interacting with a remote airflow
environments it integrates with both
Minerva shopify's browser-based oauth
authentication flow and basic author
service integration the main value of
surf for day development is the ability
to iterate quickly with an environment
close to production in terms of
resources and security with surf each
user can upload dates directly to the
staging environment with instant dag
parsing and loaded they can also trigger
list and monitor dags as well as bulk
pause removes move pause resume or fail
bags surf can also list update and
upload connections to our staging
environment surf snakes interacting with
the airflow API easy but also abstracts
away the multi-instance architecture
that jam talked about the challenge with
having multiple instances within an
environment is that the URL that you
want to send an API request to depends
on which instance your dag is deployed
to based on the environment and project
you want to interact with surf routes
its API requests to the right instance
using the surf CLI users first set their
environment and project using the surf
and set and surf project set commands
alternatively the environment and
project can be passed in through
environment and project Flags in other
commands users can list all bags
matching a specific dag ID pattern with
the surf dags list command or um and
pause or resume Days by running the surf
dags pause or surf dags remote
commands you can trigger a new diagram
with the surf dags trigger command and
fail the most recent diagram of a dag
with surf dags fail the most useful
command is probably the surf staging
Dykes push command which uploads the
specified file to the staging
environment and processes any dags
within that dag file
so to go over a quick example let's say
I've been working on this Diagon
preparation for pi data Global and I
want to test it in staging and make sure
it works
I run the
um
I run the surf staging dags push command
passing in the environment project and
the path file and within a few seconds
my deck is uploaded into GCS parsed and
airflow and I'm provided with a link to
my dag which immediately shows up in the
airflow web client
also if I die cut any import errors they
would be displayed to me in my terminal
instead of instead of having me to go to
the airflow UI the greatest benefit of
surf is the quick iteration speed while
interacting with a real airflow
environment instead of having to support
a local development alternative
so what's ahead so if we go to the next
slide
Michael next slide
uh so we're in the process of grading to
airflow 2.4 so we're about there if it
wasn't for this presentation that's what
we'll be doing right now uh so it's
always testing staging and everything we
just need to deploy it to our production
environments uh something we look
forward to is give our users proper
support for data we're scheduling that
was introduced with air for 2.4 and one
of the challenge for us is that we have
to make it work across instances because
we can imagine it's easy to imagine that
uh
a dag may want to be triggered after a
certain part of the data ingestion part
uh dags have been processed and those
two Logics or those dags are living in
different instances so they don't know
it necessarily about each other so we'll
need to make that work we do want to
adopt open lineage which was introduced
I think in airflow 2.3 or maybe 2.4
uh and foreign
doing the lineage and that origin of of
data and whatnot and also we want to add
the auto scaling of our workers which is
already supported by the main chart uh
so it's using Keta but since we're using
our own grown Shopify
deployment strategy for communities we
need to explicitly adopt it or integrate
it to our code base
and also something we want to add is the
ability to for your users from the
airflow UI to be able to search and
discover any dags across all instances
because right now if they are used if
they're not necessarily aware of that
project and whatnot
or the requirement is that the users
need to know which project they're
looking for before even so they can be
directed to an instance but if they
don't know exactly the project it's kind
of a pack
and something we look forward to is
being also to get back to the other part
of our infrastructure because we also
support like the query engine uh the
batch processing engine like spark and
whatnot so now that we've given a lot of
love to airflow we're able to focus on
other part of the system that now need
more lab so yeah
next
and we're ready for question thank you
and yeah is there any questions
where I think there will be a session in
in a few minutes
Sofia or
we have a question online is surf
available on GitHub that was one of the
bullet point we had unfairly no surf is
not because it's tightly bound to uh all
the the Shutterfly infrastructure there
is no reason for us not to share that
code other than it's so bespoke
that it may not be relevant so I would
say feel free to reach out to me and we
could even have a chat and show you some
code Snippets but it is it is unfairly
not available on GitHub sorry
if anything that maybe that's a segue
into what Astro is doing uh
astronomy or what
uh the company that support airflow a
lot of the the open source contribution
they do have a command line called
astrocli I think it does something quite
similar
uh but yeah
uh but at the same time their their main
offering is a sad suffering which
honestly depending on your scale may
make a lot of sense for us we already
add a strong uh I guess airflow culture
established at Shopify it's just that we
needed to put the project in a better
State infrastructure wise
and also by the amount of tasks that
we're doing per day the cost would have
been quite primitive but yeah but
otherwise their solution is quite
compelling
awesome thank you another question
getting the discussion section
uh question is there a zoom call no it's
not a zoom call if you type your
question in the uh YouTube chat box we
will be able to see it and answer the
questions uh no I think Bruno is
referring to a session at 12 30 my time
PST and I think it's for an hour where
we can just chat about random questions
on
yeah gotcha thank you for clarifying